das fühlt sich gut als servus s kids und
herzlich kommen zu einem neuen video
werden war aber wir werden heute wieder
in eine welt abtauchen in der ich mich
schon lange lange lange nicht mehr zu
gast war hier vielleicht auch ich weiß
es nicht und zwar spielen wir heute eine
uns habe ich mir halt metall beste
möglichkeiten immer noch matt davis ich
hoffe ich verkehr nicht ich war übrigens
gerade sn trucks wir waren gerade eben
sushi essen da der max auf dem bild im
bild auf twitter gepostet
guyon ein eisen schwert danke das nehme
ich sehr gerne mit
wir haben zwar wissen sushi essen und ja
wie sie max am bild gemacht auf twitter
das kann ich mich mal die beschreibung
packen
falls ich daran denken sollte ich hoffe
das ist der fall ist aber eigentlich
recht unwahrscheinlich aber trotzdem wir
schauen ob ich das mache
war auf jeden fall richtig richtig geil
ich habe mich wieder total fressen ich
kann ja auch ihr zweites zuhause winter
wieder kenne ich alles bezahlt essen
oder kommt noch einer
allerdings kämpfen dahinter hat sich
herausgehalten das ist wieder so ein
ganove ist die ganze zeit im hintergrund
hält so und du bist jetzt wie viel mehr
ich im eisenstädter und bis man die
besten raus kommt gut weg sie eigentlich
megageil equipment weil ich durchaus mal
die pfeile weg so eigentlich richtig
richtig gutes equipment das ist schon
was machen
und zwar ich weiß wie gut ihr euch mit
so auskennt aber ich esse am liebsten
platz und zwar diese lachs die heißen
nicht mehr geary aber irgendwie doch
keine ahnung wie viel diese reis stege
auf den solex filets oben drauf liegen
dass das allerbeste das pech am meisten
und hand rollen mit lachsen auch holt
als ihr das kennt das ist wie so eine
eistüte so zusammengerollt so komisch
und halt mit reis und lachs gefüllt dass
das absolut aller geist und da kann man
rein weißen sich dabei vorstellen das
ist ein schönes preis aber es ist kein
eis sondern dax zu schieben feuer das
ich liebe diesen dax geschmack rasieren
jetzt wissen sie es in new york
genau die übertreibst du nicht dein
leben alter was hat der denn für ein
modus aktiviert wir es gesehen denn wir
20.000 jetzt in einer millisekunde
gebogen auspacken da muss ich auf
definitiv den buben auspacken am sorry
sorry sorry
wo kommst du auch noch investieren boxen
was ist denn er hatte nur zwei herzen
nein so liebe leute runde nummer 2
spielen auf kino und so langsam bin ich
ein bisschen abgefuckt denn es braucht
eine milliarde auch noch versuche auf
rund 1000 verschiedener gründe jetzt
alle zusammen fall erstmal kann ich es
geht überhaupt nicht mehr
das ist schon mal schlimm und dann wenn
ich da mal ne gescheite runde
hinbekommen kommt zum beispiel meine
mutter rein und mal als erzählt mir ein
und macht irgendwas und ich sag mal eine
maut gibt die nicht denkt ihr das juckt
mich glaubt es nicht
lasst mich diversen wechseln
ich wechsele ich will nicht riskieren ja
genau die art von arbeit
schillig und ich kann dich seh angel
nicht mehr einsetzen wahr zu machen er
in dieser situation bleibt nur mit
vector tastatur spam ist wunderbar mit
seiner mechanischen tastatur probesprung
ja ihr braucht euch da auch kommt ob
sich darum den kollegen
du bastard alter neu bisher richtig gut
aber kompliment muss man sagen war
definitiv ein guter ruf
ich weiß nicht wie von der
beabsichtigten zweck wird es eine
goldkette
was ist für eine verkorkste runde ist
unfassbar dem halben herz überlebt den
transport von bauen.com down to me wenn
jetzt einer unterkunft nicht der übliche
stehe und ich muss sagen und ich werde
einfach gucken was im mdm irgendwas
abstauben kann nicht dass naughty dogs
ihr euch mal alle die sp will ich hab
nicht mal wie man das leder testfeld
kommen die ja mit chessbase gab es geht
los
das sind marc brendel kümmern können
irgendwie ist nicht so sehr
gerade ja boxe ich mich viel abstauben
warum ein led display das ist unfair man
ich will auch eine geht mir die
wahrscheinlich immerhin manegold
respektiert nehmen schon mit besser als
nächste damals punkte das passt auch gut
drop com wollt ihr euch boxen hier
wunderbar dann stoppe ich mal ab so
wichtig die ganze stadt wurde
das fühlt sich gut an
verzeiht mir die schadenfreude aber ich
verbiete die ganze so dreckig
weggesteckt worden
muss man dann auch mal und wie viele
tempel displays vier displays sind
einfach jetzt gerade zu diesem zeitpunkt
in meinem besitz alter und max step rein
weiß was dort gemacht hat kommt kommt
einfach rein so ich sage ich nehme auf
läuft einfach hier vorm bildschirm und
und macht irgendwas gibt die überhaupt
noch den jugendfeier weil die treffen in
spa
weil ich das kann ich weiß er in
blockhütten war es nicht so dass nur die
animation weg ist aber es trotzdem
funktioniert ich weiß es nicht
wahrscheinlich eine sehr zuverlässige
quelle aber trotzdem leute wenn sich
gefangen das sind auch nach oben da die
runde wahrscheinlich ultrakurz